It's continued bad news after bad news for
Donald Trump over the last few days.
A court ruled on Wednesday that Donald Trump
can no longer block his tax returns from a
subpoena in a grand jury in New York and will
have to turn them over.
This is part of the investigation into Donald
Trump's business practices, and it's all falling
apart for him.
This was a three zero decision in the 2nd
U.S. Circuit Court of Appeals.
The decision is Trump must turn over his tax
returns.
Great.
Right.
So now the prosecution gets the tax returns,
right?
No, not yet.
Donald Trump's lawyer, Jay Sekulow.
You might remember him from the impeachment
hearings, says that they will now appeal to
the Supreme Court.
An agreement was reached where this decision
from the lower court won't be enforced for
almost a couple of weeks so that Donald Trump
can appeal to the Supreme Court.
So, bottom line, these prosecutors are not
going to have Trump's taxes before the election,
even if these prosecutors get Donald Trump's
taxes.
That doesn't mean that we get them from them.
But something has changed.
We've already learned a ton about what is
in Donald Trump's taxes from that bombshell
New York Times report from I think it was
about 10 days ago, although at this point
it feels like six months ago where we learned
that Donald Trump paid no federal tax in 10
of the last 15 years.
We learned that Donald Trump paid only 750
dollars in federal taxes in 2016 and only
another 750 dollars in 2017.
We learned that Donald Trump has more than
420 million dollars in debt.
So the real reason that this decision matters
is that Trump is clearly becoming unglued.
And this won't help whether Trump has been
experiencing steroid induced mania for the
last few days from the dexamethasone prescription
for his covered or it's the polls that are
triggering him or whatever.
He has been unhinged even by his standards.
And we may see I don't know what the next
week will bring.
I don't know what this weekend will bring
by by by Tuesday when we're back from the
holiday.
Donald Trump may have already descended into
a full blown public narcissistic rage.
I was actually thinking the other day.
Imagine if Donald Trump realized he could
go live on Twitter via video.
And imagine he just did it and went live and
went completely crazy.
It would truly be something else.
And what has been sort of like a simmer for
a few days is quickly becoming a rolling boil.
And it could be that way by Election Day if
things keep going.
Going this way, the Supreme Court appointment
now appears as though it could be delayed.
Don Junior reportedly thinks Donald Trump
needs an intervention.
I don't yet believe that we've reached the
low point, the sort of full bottom or the
full climax, really, of Donald Trump's rage
yet.
And as far as the taxes go, The New York Times
themselves might have more documents and may
actually drop a bombshell in the next couple
of weeks.
They may find a way.
Remember that The New York Times decided they
weren't going to publish the actual tax documents
because they believed that the copies they
have probably because of some markings or
stamps or whatnot that are on them, would
expose who their sources on Trump's tax documents.
It's conceivable that the source will say
out me or that The New York Times will find
a way to release the documents without outing
the source.
And so we may even see the actual tax documents
before this is all said and done after this
decision was made by the court.
Donald Trump quickly went nuclear.
Within minutes of the decision, he went to
Twitter to deliver another all capital letters
rant where he said, wow, now do something
about this.
The biggest of all political scandals in history.
Biden, Obama and crooked Hillary led this
treasonous plot.
Biden shouldn't be allowed to run.
Got caught.
Now, in all seriousness, as far as the appeal
to the Supreme Court on this decision, should
the Supreme Court even hear this case?
Of course, it's the president.
And, of course, Donald Trump has every right
to appeal each decision against him on different
grounds, if that's what he wants to do.
But at some point, does it become frivolous?
Different legal experts have different perspectives
on that.
But I suppose at.
Some point we will see.
So the plan for today and for next week, we
are going to hear from some of you.
We are going to talk later on in the program
about whether Trump's corona virus helps or
hurts him.
How long?
I believe it will take the final results of
the 2020 election to be given to us.
We will talk about the recent trends with
older voters moving towards Joe Biden.
And away from Donald Trump.
Monday, we are off.
Call it Columbus Day.
Call it Indigenous Peoples Day.
We tend to take federal holidays off.
The staff really needs it.
So we will be off on Monday and then back
Tuesday through Election Day.
And it is going to be a wild, wild few weeks.
So I'm glad that you are with me here.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman membership.
Always is the best way to support our work.
And the show you can grab a membership at
join Pacman dot com and you have only about
three and a half weeks left to use the coupon
code.
Twenty, twenty.
Now we started the coupon code.
Twenty, twenty now.
When I determined I used my judgment to determine
it is now the election.
The election has started.
That code will work until November 3rd.
And then it is.
Bye-Bye.
Twenty now saves you sixty six percent off
of the membership of your choice.
Grab one it.
Join Pacman dot com and we'll be back right
after this.